[Applause]
I've watched you for a long time nobody
nobody throws it better than you do what
a great job you did max thank under
pressure as well under pressure as well
but you know max said we have the
experience we don't fold under pressure
which puts more pressure on the team but
that's one of those things right and
that's exactly what happened you didn't
fold under pressure from then on the
Nationals won two games for every loss
which is a tremendous percentage winning
percentage as you battled for every win
Gerardo Parra changed his woke-up song
to baby shark that was a favorite of his
two-year-old daughter and it became the
anthem for the Nats fans everywhere and
I tell you what that turned out to be a
very very powerful little tune in the
final weeks of the regular season
you were down six runs against the Mets
in the bottom of the ninth you scored
seven runs I do remember that well
including an amazing three-run homer by
Kurt Suzuki where's Kurt come in say a
couple words come on
I love you all I love you all thank you
[Applause]
what a job he did I didn't know that was
gonna happen
and by the way max will you come over